um five teams have prime time games this
year no eight teams have five prime time
games or eight teams have eight prime
time games one of those is correct eight
have five that's what it is cowboys
packers 49ers rams bucks chiefs ravens
and patriots and i i can i can get
behind that right the rams didn't make
the playoffs the cowboys didn't make the
playoffs but they have that national
brand the bucks didn't make the playoffs
but but they have tom brady i can get
behind that i don't have a problem with
those many teams having five primetime
games any of those stand out to you is
not belonging
well the interesting one will be the
patriots i mean there'll be an
interesting story no matter what because
of tom brady leaving and what will bill
belichick make of this team without tom
brady that will be fascinating to watch
but if jared stidham isn't the guy
that's gonna that's gonna be tough later
on in the season if we're watching a
quarterback that is clearly not the guy
playing games with the patriots but that
would be the most fascinating question
mark i think all the other teams that
you listed have uh either you know are
really really good or have national
prominence where you can't have an nfl
schedule without at least a few cowboys
games on sunday night football to make
you feel like you're at home you know it
just it just that says that that is the
uh the totem in inception to remind you
that we're still in reality is that the
cowboys are playing on a sunday night
football game
and and this is what's fascinating about
this phase of the patriots existence
because over the course of the last 20
years they have dominated the national
football league they have become a
national brand
and the real question is this
do they have staying power on the
national stage
even if they stink because the cowboys
more often than not over the past 25
years have stunk the cowboys haven't
been to the nfc championship game since
their last super bowl win super bowl 30
against the steelers in early 1996 but
they still
are the one team if you ask a network
who do you want on your air more often
than any other team they're going to say
the cowboys we want cowboys games night
games late afternoon thanksgiving
holidays anytime anywhere cowboys even
though they have been mediocre at best
all things considered the past quarter
century will that happen now first of
all the patriots have to become mediocre
which may be a ridiculous proposition
but but can the patriots continue to
stay in the upper echelon even if they
are a seven and nine six and ten eight
and eight team what do you think well
well i i think for this year
specifically
bill belichick is not gonna have a bad
team because i just don't i can't
imagine bill belichick not having a team
that will find a way to at least be
relevant in the standings so i think
even if they're not at the upper echelon
if they're not one of the teams going
for a buy if they're not you know 12
wins 13 wins like they've been used to i
think the story line of bill belichick
trying to find a way to get into the
playoffs with jared stidham will be
fascinating and will be compelling
television and bill belichick in general
is compelling television so he and he
alone
will carry that torch uh in terms of
prime time games now what will happen
when he retires if that's 5 10 15 years
who knows but for this season
specifically
i think their story is very interesting
and does deserve to be on prime time
and and here's what makes the point that
i just made even more amazing because
you're right as long as belichick is
with the patriots the patriots are going
to be a compelling team but
barry switzer chan gailey dave campo
bill parcells wade phillips jason
garrett
those are the cowboys coaches for the
past 25 years other than parcells none
of these guys is going to make us say
well oh we better pay attention to the
cowboys
and the fact that they have had that
staying power what is it is it is it the
the silver helmet with the blue star
is it the joneses i mean you know this
is the question i need to ask steven
today and i will
and and there's got to be a tactful way
to put it i mean you know hey steven why
do you think your team continues to be
so compelling when it's not very good i
mean but that's the case is it jerry
jones is that why is it what is it
i'll tell you there's a few things one's
a stadium
uh i actually do think that matters the
stadium the cowboy stadium does feel
like a big prime time game stadium
because we we were used to it even when
it was the stadium before jerry's world
with you know the opening in so that god
can watch the cowboys it felt different
in dallas jerry jones is absolutely part
of that and then i would throw in as a
third point the teams in their division
the eagles and the giants and the
redskins are teams that have had history
that uh you know if the cowboys are
playing the giants those are two big
markets so i i think when you add all
that together
it keeps that relevancy even when they
have been backed
you make an excellent point there and
and i'm reluctant to give you that kind
of credit i don't want back to the 70s i
think back to the 70s when i first
discovered football
and if you want and there are plenty of
old games on youtube from the 70s and a
lot of the nfl stadiums were crap holes
for lack of a better term and you can
see it when you watch the games
and there was something about texas
stadium and it may be just as simple as
the lighting but there was something
about the way those games looked on tv
they jumped off the screen back in the
days of the old
you know
rear projection tube and
whatever they cathode ray tube and the
big giant fake wood paneling and low def
there was something about the cowboys
games the way they looked i remember the
first time i was ever in dallas in 1994
and i was going from the airport to
hotel and the
the vehicle passed by the the the
stadium and i saw it it's like that's it
it looks like crap i mean you expect it
to be
palatial on the outside because those
images from from years and years of
football when all the other teams had
crappy stadiums there was just something
about it and maybe that is the thing it
gave the cowboys an intangible
indefinable but very real quality where
everything they did felt special and it
stayed that way for the past 40 years
even though the past 25 years has been
not that much special
and think about it this mike to even uh
go further on my fantastic point two to
one me the nfl has had a lot of stadium
over you know what i mean there's a lot
of new stadiums why why do some stadiums
feel more special why does lambo and
soldier field and dallas stadium even
though it's different than what they had
but it feels the same because it's
jerry's world and it's huge it's
enormous and it's all these things
i think there's history in some of these
stadiums and that's a little bit more
rare as opposed to maybe baseball or
hockey or anywhere else the the history
in
the select stadiums the nfl i'm even
thinking of like how much of a bummer it
is to watch the 49ers play not a
candlestick like i'm still kind of not
over that so i think that these older
stadiums or the stadiums that feel like
they have history add an element to the
broadcast that you just can't you can't
really put your finger on
but and and here's the other thing too i
i had no idea that we would go down this
rabbit hole but i think it's a
compelling conversation i'm a genius
but you know what i was at soldier field
last year for the first time ever
and i was in awe
of soldier field
and and it just occurred to me now for
whatever reason
and you may disagree with me i don't
think that that same sense of awe when
you're there comes across when the game
is televised am i wrong yeah well i
think the aerial shots definitely play
when it's by the lake maybe not
i think that's also the bears are just
bad so that that
when that stadium but it doesn't affect
the cowboys yeah i know when that
stadium is rocking though it does feel
different than uh newer stadiums i just
there are just a lot if you look around
the nfl i'm just doing it off the top of
my head how many stadiums out there the
superdomes another great great point a
superdome game feels different so maybe
soldier field shouldn't even be in that
conversation i'm fine with that i'll
concede that because the bears have been
so bad but there are certain stadiums
that have history and meaning behind
them and games just feel bigger when
they're played there
and i'm telling you the lighting has so
much to do with it you're right the
games at the superdome you you can like
there are certain stadiums where
even if it wasn't the saints playing you
can tell it's the superdome just
the just by the picture the lighting
everything you can tell instantly it's a
superdome you can tell it's uh cowboy
stadium you you and you can tell it's
heinz field which really doesn't have
the same history that three rivers
stadium had but there are certain that
just that is obvious from the get-go
where you are and then others where it's
like i don't know what stadium that is
and that has something to do by the way
by the way you won't be seeing any shots
of ford field in prime time this year
the lions are the one team that has zero
prime time
and
every game
every game for the lions this year is in
that one o'clock eastern time window
except for thanksgiving which i think
starts a little earlier i can't remember
but um but yeah lions lions get no night
games okay let me say i'll use that
instead no night games for the detroit
lions in 2020.
okay but that is that is still
considered a prime time game because
it's a thursday it's something different
it's a quirk in the schedule uh the
lions another one
i wish you have a weird definition of
prime time you have a very
two to two two to two i'm not going to
let you have i'm not going to concede
that one no prime time
thursday morning is not prime time the
silver dome bring back the silver dome i
know it still exists and it's uh barren
and i think in disrepair maybe they
actually they they actually just finally
the last year or two
uh finally blew it up but that's another
one where i wish they had figured out a
way to have the silver dome still exist
because there's history there
no yeah yeah i think it would have taken
a lot to get the silver dome back to a
point where they could play games it
reminded me like one of the scenes of
the original jumanji movie where the
jungle takes over the house i mean it
some some of the images of the silver
dome were fascinating to look at how
that place just got overrun by nature
through 10 years of of not being used at
all so um all right let's see what else
we have here uh
yes any other points on the primetime
schedule you would like to make big cat
before we take a break i'm good i'm
scheduled
yeah i i love that every team still gets
a prime time game that's probably my
favorite part of the nfl schedule where
you can make sure that your team does
get at least one standalone game where
it's like hey everyone's gonna be
watching you um and i think that that's
the definition of prime time so it's
still two to one me
all right i still think it's two to two
primed you cannot have a thursday
afternoon game in prime time we started
down this road last hour when you tried
to say that washington playing in the
four o'clock eastern slot on
thanksgiving counts as their prime time
game i reject that as well so no
primetime games for washington no
primetime games for the lions and i
don't know you know coaches use
everything they can to motivate their
players
is there any way do you use that like
they don't have any respect for us they
didn't put us in prime time i bet that
that matt patricia and or ron rivera
will find a way to get their guys fired
up that they think we're going to stink
this year look they didn't even bother
to put us in prime time let's go out and
prove to all of them that we're a prime
time team or something did you did you
just ask if a head football coach uses
uh the the smallest slight in the entire
world is motivation yeah
yeah
yeah and even even slights that aren't
slights even if they have to make stuff
up they'll do it if it gets their guys
properly motivated
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports